please to have on right now the general
manager and president to football
operations of the team that he spent all
16 Hall of Fame campaigns with back in
his playing days the Denver Bronco is
John Elway how are you John I'm doing
great thank you I appreciate you joining
this program and and I I just want to
make sure you're all comfortable you
like everybody else
just in sweats when you're just hanging
around the house just chilling out you
just like the rest of us john i am i
exactly am yeah it's kind of nice it's
not it's uh it's taken me a while to get
used to because we've had to work the
last couple weeks I've uh we really
don't have a lot to do right now it's a
little bit different I got to find
things to do which I'm not used to doing
I bet so and just I'm curious as to what
you thought about this draft we all know
the circumstances under which why you
and the rest of your colleagues had to
draft the way that you did was there
anything to it that your thought you
know what III wouldn't mind if we did
this from now on John yeah I think that
we really got a lot done I mean I think
that with the space that we had and not
having to deal with a lot of other
things that you have to deal with at the
office that you know it was a pretty
good set up you know I think draft day a
you know job day was good my kids were
here so people got you know they got to
see kind of how everything worked and
we're intrigued by that I think it was
great with with that and then but you
know the only thing I didn't like is a
you know I like a little bit more
communication private communication
which was hard to do when you're on
zoom' but we were able to do that with
you know on our cell phones and those
type of things so as time went on we got
more and more comfortable with it or by
the end by the time the drafter I think
everybody's ready to go and I think it
worked out pretty well yeah I mean cuz I
spoke to Howie Roseman of the Eagles a
couple days ago and he thought that the
first couple of nights he thought that
maybe the way everything was going was
in fact tamping down trades or
conversations and then Saturday when
things became a little bit more one
would say I guess normal that that's
where things began to take off is is
what you just said kind of playing into
what how he said
yeah yeah no question I think Howie's
right I think that thing you know there
everybody was a little bit cautious in
first couple days because obviously
nobody wanted to make a mistake or
forget disconnected somehow and all of a
sudden we're going to miss a pic and so
I think that's where most of the stress
came from you know when this set up
rather than what we've done in the past
but it ended up being just fine as you
said and you know people started doing
making some more moves and doing some
different things up on the last day
which you know once everybody got
comfortable and then in terms of like
being a private conversation so you
would just step away from the zoom and
go to the other part of your your
beautiful home draft setup and and have
a conversation on your cell phone is
that how it worked yeah yeah exactly
yeah so we do that and you know we
didn't have a whole lot of those but a
couple of situations just to look at
different options and so yeah that's how
we instead of being I'll just you know
look you know look at Vick next to me on
one side Russell met Russell on the
other side you know we just had to do it
via the cell phone so that made a little
bit tougher but once we got used to that
you know things got pretty and it went
pretty well alright as you settled into
your chair in your house on opening
night of the draft John Illinois if I
had told you you could sit at 15 and
Jerry Judy would fall to you you would
have said to me what I said there's
about a 10% chance of that I think you
know all our preparation and everything
that we've done up to that point in time
you know and even in all our mock drafts
Jerry never got to us in our mock draft
that's what it was yeah you know as a
surprise a surprise to us no really I
would be dependent on what you know
especially with the Raiders and the
Niners in front of us with you know they
needed wide receiver
they had wide receiver needs and as well
as you never know which direction the
Jets were going to go even though it was
you know we thought it was going to be
tackled but you never did know so
there's a lot of things that could have
happened in front of us that you know
that we wouldn't have ended up with
Jerry but fortunately it fell the right
way and you fell into our laps and you
know we're thrilled about that you try
to knock on somebody's during the top
ten at all
yeah we did you know I think that you
know we did that but I think with where
we are as a football team felt that
we had a lot of good tent pics and so we
had you know we had five in the first
hundred pics and so I think but where we
were as a football team draft capital
was more important than moving up and we
felt like even at 15 no matter how it
felt there and so and then that's why we
didn't it was too much to move up too
costly to move up so we felt like we're
gonna get a good football player there
plus without having to give up any jobs
yes so are you also saying when you're
mocking this out that did you might not
have thought may Aachen Gruden we're
gonna take rugs in that spot
John no no that was a bit of a surprise
we didn't have even though what we do
with because what was different this
year with our mocks is usually our
scouts are in and so we we mop with all
our Scouts and they have three or four
teams apiece and then we do the mocks
that way but this year we did it where
we took all the mock drafts that were
there and we ran those scenarios and
then with each mock what was left and I
don't know that there was ever a mock
with rugs going 12 and so therefore
that's why I think it was such a
different situation for us because we
had been through that scenario and then
you went back to the Penn State wide
receiver store in the second round
John we did we did you know and I would
tell you this he was kind of our target
in the second round from the very GetGo
depending on how the first round so I
didn't know exactly how I was gonna fall
and so but he was going to be kind of
our target in that second round because
we loved his explosiveness we loved the
speed and and the way that he plays and
so he can really you know threaten the
defense so he was kind of our target now
nothing and not knowing how the first
round was going to go I was still
prepared to go receiver receiver and I
know they did helpdesk on receiver
receiver because of the fact that if we
hadn't gone receiver in the first round
I think there's been a lot of people
that would better try to jump us in the
second round and so I think there's a
lot of people behind us that kind of let
us know that that was kind of hammer was
their guy but I think you know with us
sitting there not going up as well as
having drafted wide receiver in the
first round I think people were people
were more
we you know we're fine sitting there
thinking oh we weren't gonna draft and
another wide receiver so yeah that well
I know you went you went wide receiver
wide receiver John why I mean obviously
you know there are a lot of potential
answers to that but why did you do that
well I mean I think that we want to get
more explosive on the offensive side and
so with Jerry there at 50 and obviously
the great route runner and experience
and all kinds of production in one and
then hammer at two with the speed and
his ability to be able to stretch the
field and I think over the last couple
of years you know we've lost Thomas and
you know we lost the game went to
Emanuel Sanders last year and so you
know we were little depleted in the wide
receivers and we weren't hadn't been as
nearly as explosive on the offensive
side that we needed to be so we made the
commitment that we're going to get
better on the offensive side we need to
put more points on the board and so we
kind of made that a point this year
going in that we need to get some speed
and some depth that wide receiver and so
that was a goal going in John Elway
Denver Broncos general manager in front
office executive here on the Rich Eisen
show what you see out a lot last year
that checked a box of what you evaluated
of him you know I think the thing about
quarterbacks is you you know you can see
the physical talent on tape you can see
how they throw out how they move you
know how they go through reads how
they're able to get through reason so
progressions and all that you can see
all that on tape and I always think that
you know the number one thing with
quarterbacks is very difficult to read
is how are they going to handle the
situation how are they going to handle
the pressure the NFL and the lights on
the lights get turned on you know how
are they going to handle it and I think
you know 80% of that of quarterbacks
that make it and fail are the ones that
they fail they can't they can't adjust
to that and can't get used to that and
understand you know the the expectations
of them in that position and so I think
what I saw what we saw Andrew was the
back we knew he had the physical ability
to move around he was for six guys to
come by last year could make all the
throws and and but how he was going to
handle you know the whole situation of
getting in there when the lights turned
on and I think that was the most
encouraging thing that we saw was you
know what he enjoyed playing the game he
came in like
you know he'd been there before he was
able to bounce back from mistakes and
not let mistakes bother him it bounced
back from him and so I think you know
what we saw mostly in those last five
games that he started that you know he
has the mental capacity not only to
handle the offense but also to handle
all the things outside that with the
pressure that goes along with being that
being a quarterback both in terms of you
know for the team in terms of handling
things John how does an NFL 100 all-time
team quarterback delegate to others
potentially to develop a quarterback
that he himself has drafted how do you
work on that genre well I mean I think
he number one is you know you try to get
you try to put him in the best system
that you can put him into where you have
a chance to be successful that's why to
me coaching is so important and then the
next thing is to be ready to be able to
have people around him that can help
they can help make him successful and
give him the ability that go different
places and have the opportunity like I
said to be successful so you know you
got you got to have both those I think
you know with that Shermer coming in as
our offensive coordinator this year is
getting tremendous amount of experience
and dealing with young quarterbacks as
well Mike Shula came with him to be a
quarterback coach there's a tremendous
about a tremendous amount of experience
also so you know you mix the coaching
with the talent around the quarterback
and you know to me that gives them the
best chance to be successful but that
said I mean if I'm a you're John freakin
Hill way though you know what I mean
like you don't you don't chime in well I
will say is that you know what you're
gonna be sitting you're gonna touch on
the top of that pedestal and as soon as
they do they're gonna try to knock you
off the pedestal yeah and you got to be
tough enough to stay on top of that
pedestal and not allow them to knock you
off it and so that comes with you know
with confidence and the confidence in
yourself your ability to it
understanding that the Kate the world is
going to cleave at some point in time
you're going to have a poor game and the
world's gonna cave in around you and
it's how you handle that coming out and
how you handle next week because you're
gonna have a lot of good times and
you're gonna have a lot of tough times
and to tell you if easy handle these the
good times are easy to handle it
how you handle the tough times in your
career and how you come through that and
as long as you've got your nose to the
grindstone yeah you know that you can do
what you're able to do and get out there
and continue to work at it
then you'll grind through that and
because it's a grind
they said they're gonna ear on that
pedestal for your whole career and all
they try to do is shoot you off that's
your job stay there but you don't you
don't ever pull Locke aside or anybody
aside and and or you say hey my door is
open because again I like having
conversations with him and then and
again I don't do a lot of that because
there's a quarterback they're getting
instruction from a lot of different
points of view from their coaches
offensive coordinator as well as a
quarterback coach head coach jumps and
everyone's about to but my my thing is
big picture with him right my deal is to
be there for support help them through
the different times that maybe he's
going through that I can give him my
experience and how I got through this so
there's there's no question the
conversations I have with him were
definitely under the big picture of play
not necessarily each different play but
the idea of how to play the game and and
you know how to handle everything that
goes along with that position so ya know
the door's always open I talked to Drew
you know we haven't talked about this
offseason but definitely plan on talking
do more and I mean had these friends
that I've had to be able to help them
with along that way in the few minutes I
have left with you John Elway I want to
go memory lane with you a little bit
here I remember the first time I saw Pat
Bowlen
you know with NFL Network which would
never have existed without him period
end of story I just thought this is the
coolest guy I've maybe I've ever come
across you know with the glasses it was
a leather
it was a leather jacket give me the
coolest bowling story for you what's the
coolest Pat Bowlen story that's in your
he was a cruel dude I think the Dean I
think he was 42 or 43 years old when he
brought the Broncos and so imagine 42
years old and on and then I felt then
that would be a lot of fun I think that
he was one guy that took full advantage
of that
and but you know you had a great sense
for you said without you know without
hand then if I'm Network as far as some
of the different things that he did cuz
I think he was on every committee to
possibly be on it that the league level
yeah but just had really a sixth sense
of about people the right people in
right positions he was not a guy that
you know would jump in and have a bunch
of suggestions or tell you to do
something but you know he always wanted
to be in the know you always wanted to
know what you're doing and you wanted to
know why and so you know as well you had
to why he was very easy to work for if
you didn't have the live and you know as
much you know wanted to know you know
then you have to have some kind of why
of what you're doing so but it was very
easy it was great it's like you said cuz
I played a lot of golf with him he's fun
to play golf with and you know was a guy
that it's just a great owner and you
know will be missed forever so we I got
Favre on the next hour John what was it
like and that's Super Bowl Joe you're
laughing already give me good Favre
story what do you got huh come on John I
you know he's a guy that you know every
time he's on I you know he he's fun to
talk to he's got a great sense of humor
he's got that disposition that you know
he doesn't care what the world thinks
and I you know just a tremendously funny
person that you know it's fun to be
around and so there's you know there are
so many Brett Favre stories and and the
thing is you know you always used to
kill me when all over there in the Pro
Bowl and he used to kill me for my walk
he he had me totally pegged when it came
down to how I walked and so he spent a
lot of time walking around the swimming
pool when we had a break at the Pro Bowl
showing that the move that how I walked
and so but it was a very good imitation
what was it what was it you got you the
sachet I don't know wasn't know you know
a little overdone but I'm sure it was it
got a good laugh every time he did it
well you got a deny I'm a Super Bowl you
had to deny him that John you know
that attica well we snuck up on him you
know they're defending champs and they
had a great football team but we had a
great day we're able to run the football
and really kind of keep them off the
field leave you know even so they were
still in the football game till late and
you know so we were fortunate so they
had a great football team but we were
able to finally get over the hump and
you know I appreciate him saying you
know what in a grammarian saying that if
he was going to lose anybody wonder it's
fine listen to me which I know it's
still hurting lose him but you know baby
feel good that you know that he said
that and so I've always had a great deal
of you know respectful Brett what he's
been as a football player in this league
and also his personality and and you
know he's just a great great a lot of
time to be around that said he shot a 79
yesterday when he played golf you could
take him there right John easy being
that good they must be working on a
little bit how much how much Katie when
you have Matt we don't play golf and
played golf together for 20 years and
saying like this huh make sure that you
know like to get together play some golf
how much candy would you have to give
them how much on the course 79 does that
then the user shoot in the seventies or
I don't know I don't know I ask couple
shots inside I would think so are you
scratching so what you saying I don't
know are you scratched John you don't
want to say it in public because you
don't want to give it out all right John
last one for you how often you think of
the the drive do you ever think about
that
I mean um you ever sit around just
thinking about one of your great moments
in the history of the game you ever
think about that you know you know you
know you know the fun thing about this
whole thing of being quarantined in
homer's and not any likely TV there's
been a lot more you know things on TV
from the path
older NFL games right I was able to see
the drive game and take a peek at it
yeah I think about it I mean that was
that was probably you know other than
the Super Bowl is the biggest game of my
life doesn't affect it that was one that
put me on them happen especially with
everything it was in my fourth year and
everything that I'd gone through as far
as with the draft and and getting traded
to Denver and so you know I'm struggling
my first year and so to be able to
continue to get better and then finally
in the fourth year be able to to have
the drive and be able to do that get the
win in overtime really kind of put me on
the map okay so from that point on it
was about trying to choose those Super
Bowls down but yeah the drive will
always be you know right there at the
top as far as games that I play just
because of what it did for me I'm
mandated to ask you when you watch the
drive again just recently what what did
you did you learn anything you forget
anything did you pick something up what
do you what did you what you get from
that you know it's funny I can still
remember what I was thinking when I
watch the game I can still remember each
play what I was thinking afterwards and
how they how did the whole thing percent
now I don't remember each point once we
get an overtime sure but a blur you know
it is exciting to watch because you know
I don't I think probably the last time I
saw that was 10-15 years ago and so you
know you can't go back and you relive it
and you know I'm gonna almost be 60 year
old I'll be 60 years old this year and
so to be able to look back at that mouth
getting to the point was that really me
just gonna be so you know so long ago
but you know what it does is it makes
you want to play again and you know wish
you had that 25 30 year old body to be
able to go do that helps to know the
ending to though right oh it does
there's no question yeah this it's a
it's a real positive but you know at the
time it's not nearly as much fun at the
times that is looking back when you're
almost 60 yeah I mean I'm just looking
at the ratings for this right here in
front of me they didn't watch it in
Cleveland that's odd
they just turned the television sets off
John that was you know I remember that
was a loud Stadium and they were playing
great they had a great football team did
you know old Cleveland Municipal the
baseball
it was a dark dreary day was cold I
think is around 10 degrees it's kind of
damp and wet and you know kind of one of
those old things that I used when I was
washed I look back at like you know when
Jim Brown with playing and those guys
are playing that's what Canon when you I
look back at that now it's it's look
it's the same look except it's me
playing and so you know the you know
it's just a great memory and just the
way it all came about to where you know
we walked out of that place and it was
though you could hear you know you could
hear a penny drop on the ground it was
so quiet and so you know unfortunately
too and the next three years we're able
to beat him here in Denver the a chant
chip game so they've always it's been a
nemesis for for them we've been a
nemesis with them for a long time you
could say that again hey John appreciate
the time always love our chats I could
chat with you all day but I do have
Favre coming up and I can't wait to tell
them that uh
you still have some strokes to get back
to the course John I can't wait to tell
them that make it work a good deal for
me so you don't get on the golf course
I'll be more than happy to negotiate
that for you we'll chat soon
that's not a good rich thank you you
take care no thank you that's John Elway
everybody how great was that
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here